you know an emotional night but what is
this journey meant to you and how would
you sort of describe what you've been on
this journey was a surprise and it was
it proved to me that your life can
change on a random Thursday afternoon by
you know by saying yes to something that
you were previously terrified of didn't
think you had the energy for wanted to
stay in bed actually because it was more
comfortable and I said
yes and by having just said yes Sasha
did so much of the leg work for me until
I could feel comfortable enough to say
okay I can breathe now and in and I want
and it just shows that you know other
things in life can be that way
and loving something again and loving
being on a set these are things I
haven't been a part of for a long time
I broke my heart open and I just have so
much respect and love for everyone here
I'm very very sad to walk away even if
it's for the best for me it just doesn't
make it easier I just I'm I I love it
here and what is this working uh working
with some I've been like for you
she's part of the family she's family
now I will always have her back if she
needs anything and it really has you
know this is what it feels like winning
a mirrorable trophy and
um she's the trophy and um she was just
phenomenal tonight and every week she
comes in and she just delivers you know
every the start of every week is so
difficult for summer but yet at the end
of the week the way that the dance looks
and how much dedication and all the
obstacles that she got goes over it's
phenomenal with this woman this is only
on the beginning of something massive
again
just this this night I mean how would
you describe it I mean it was
to have this room filled with so much
listening and love
for every dancer in here and then for me
even when you say it's time to bow out
and to have
so much love and support for that which
is typically something that
just people go quietly when they have to
say goodbye when they've hit a weakness
or an injury and to just say it with
love goodbye and have people Embrace
that aspect also of my life which
represents other people having to take
care of themselves if they've gone to
their limit then
I mean that's resounding love that's
resounding support and empathy and I'm
just so proud of everyone here